destroyed factories abandoned homes and
uniforms as far as the eye can see
this is novorotska a small town on the
government-held side of the front lines
in eastern ukraine
a town that was just getting by
then war struck
over there is hora that's where the
separatists are
we used
it was like one big city everyone went
there to work
traces of the war were bound here in
norfolk jobs do not
was born and raised here for years she
taught history at the local school
during the heaviest fighting tatiana
became the town's deputy mayor
her job included making sure civilian
casualties were cared for
after the daily
we suffered our last direct hits back in
february
seven years have passed since the war
began
fewer and fewer people still believe
we'll ever see the end of this
that both sides will reunify
miles of trenches and minefields now cut
novoroska
off from the big cities that used to be
practically in its backyard
if ever a town needed to reinvent itself
it's this one but how
te chana costco thinks she's found the
answer here at the town's overgrown
cemetery
this is the yanson family
the german founders of new york the
ukrainian new york that is
that's what novoroska was officially
called until 1951.
the name dates back to the 19th century
one story popular among locals is that
one of their founding fathers visited
the real deal in the u.s
and returned to ukraine wishing to see
his hometown flourish like its namesake
after world war ii soviet authorities
proceeded to erase all memories of the
town's german past
they selected a name as bland as it gets
new york
became novorodske or newtown
this used to be called gartenstrasse or
garden street in german this was the
heart of new york
tatyana is convinced that returning to
the town's previous name is its only
hope for survival
if navorosco went back to being new york
headlines would surely be guaranteed
our foreign minister has already
suggested we host a u.n
assembly here in our ukrainian new york
let them come we're ready for them
new york already has a petrol station a
pizzeria
and a handful of clubs it seems all
that's missing is a baseball team
and the legal underpinning a draft law
to officially change the town's name
has been submitted to ukraine's
parliament and is pending approval
but not everyone here shares tatiana's
enthusiasm seventy-five-year-old
michael's garden
is directly on the front lines just
getting to his house
requires a permit
it's quiet enough today but who knows
what'll happen tomorrow
the shooting never really stops here
michalo tells us how restricted his life
has become
the buses stop running land mines now
prevent him from visiting his parents
graves
he's skeptical that changing the town's
name will make any difference
i was born back when this was
was still named after stalin at the time
what is changing a name going to achieve
we need jobs
talk isn't enough
time for spring cleaning at the
playground the town's military
authorities
have neither the time nor the resources
for this kind of thing
it's volunteers like tatyana who fill
the gap she's there
wherever she's needed encouraging her
neighbours to keep on going
to never give up
who knows maybe if this ends up as new
york again
then perhaps the other side will stop
shelling us
after all who's going to want to pick a
fight with the americans
might sound a little far-fetched but
it's better than sitting around and
waiting
better to dream of new york than to do
nothing giving up
just isn't an option